Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Seventeen: equality between the sexes.
Equality between men and women is today one of the Danish society's basic values.
It has not always been so.
There are still challenges, but there has clearly been more equality between the two sexes in Denmark over the last 150 years.
That is not least due to the women's movement's fight for women to have the same rights as men and to change society's traditional view of gender roles, for example whether the man should decide over the woman, or whether women can have sexual relationships before marriage.
One thing is that men and women have to a large extent got equal rights and duties in our society.
Another thing is that men and women still do differently in a number of important areas.
Equal pay, ligeløn.
One of the most important questions within equality has been the fight for equal pay.
In 1914, men who worked in industry or crafts earned on average 55 øre per working hour and women only 30 øre.
And female teachers had until 1919 to make do with two thirds of the male teachers' pay.
The pay differences between men and women have gradually become smaller over the last 100 years.
A milestone on the way was when the Folketing in 1976, after demands from the EF, now the EU, passed a law on equal pay for the same work.
But there is still a bit missing.
In 2022, women earned on average 12 percent less than men in hourly pay across the whole labour market.
Calculations that take account of women's and men's different levels of, for example, education, work experience, industry and job function typically show a difference in hourly pay of 4 to 7 percent.
That the difference has become smaller is due especially to men over recent decades having fallen behind women when it comes to education.
Both sexes are better educated than before, but the development has benefited women most.
In 1960 about five percent of women and 16 percent of men in an age cohort completed a higher education, that is above upper secondary level.
In 2023 it is about 64 percent of women and 45 percent of men.
So today more women than men complete a higher education, en videregående uddannelse; the answer in Danish is kvinder, women.
In addition there have come more female leaders, although they are still in the minority.
In 2025 the share of female leaders in the Danish labour market was 32 percent.
At the top management level, however, the share is smaller: among members of companies' boards women make up 19 percent and 16 percent of the chief executives.
There is however a markedly larger share of female leaders in the public sector compared with the private sector.
A large part of the pay difference that remains is due to there still being most male leaders, and to men and women working in different trades.
The difference in pay between the different occupational groups in the public sector was determined over 50 years ago.
That is, at a time when society still looked less equally on the two sexes than today.
Therefore some of the traditional "women's trades", for example pedagogues and social and health care assistants, are placed considerably lower than the typical "men's trades", for example police officers.
There is however disagreement about exactly how much is still missing before there is "equal pay for the same work".
That is because in practice it is difficult to assess when work is "the same", that is, exactly what value different occupational groups' and different employees' work creates.
Maternity and parental leave, barsel.
A further important question about equality concerns maternity leave.
In 2002 the present legislation came with 52 weeks in total: four weeks before and 14 weeks after the birth to the mother and two weeks to the father in connection with the birth.
Of the remaining 32 weeks of parental leave, father and mother must each take at least nine weeks.
The other 14 weeks can then be freely distributed between the parents.
In practice, however, it is still the women who take by far the biggest part, on average about 80 percent, of the leave, while men take about 20 percent.
The difference means that women, because of their absence from the workplace, do not rise as much in pay as men do.
Conversely men have less time with their children.
Some of this difference will presumably correct itself in future.
Sexual offences, seksuelle krænkelser.
In 2017, a new international movement spread via social media and the hashtag Me Too, the so-called Me Too movement.
The movement's target was sexual offences and harassment.
The occasion was a series of accusations from several women in the American film industry about abuse.
There were many of them, as it turned out.
The movement quickly spread to many countries, where women stepped forward publicly saying that they too had experienced similar things.
In Denmark the movement only really broke through in 2020, after the TV host Sofie Linde at a gala show with an award ceremony for comedians began, in August 2020, to talk about something completely different from comedians, namely sexism, sexisme, and her own experiences within the TV industry with sexual harassment and offences.
It became a spark that lit a big fire.
Because from there the development went fast.
There were many who had similar experiences, not least in the media industry, the film industry, the music industry, cultural life and in political life.
This meant that prominent politicians were forced to resign, and that well-known media personalities lost their jobs.
Sexual offences and harassment are also found in many other places, but it is less visible when it takes place in less high-profile industries.
It can for example be shop assistants, social and health care assistants or nurses.
When sexual offences are committed by leaders or people in superior positions, it is also about power, because the employees, for fear of their careers, may find it difficult to say no.
Among other things for this reason the trade union movement has also got a focus on sexual offences.
One of the results is that many workplaces are working to change the culture at the workplace, make it easier for employees to report the offenders and crack down harder on offences when they happen.
In 2021 a so-called consent-based legislation on rape came into force.
It aims to better protect persons against unwanted sex.
As the law was until then, it was rape if violence, threats of violence or other illegal coercion was used.
Or if intercourse was carried out even though the victim was unable to say no, for example was unconscious.
With the new law you can also be punished for rape if intercourse is carried out without both parties having given consent, even if for example neither violence nor threats have been used.
A consent does not mean that both parties must say "yes".
A consent to intercourse can be expressed both by words and by action.
Here is your recap for Episode Seventeen.
Equality between men and women has grown over the last 150 years, thanks to the women's movement.
In 1914 men in industry or crafts earned 55 øre an hour and women 30 øre; female teachers got two thirds of male teachers' pay until 1919.
The Folketing passed the equal pay law in 1976 after demands from the EF.
In 2022 women earned on average 12 percent less per hour; with education, experience, industry and job function taken into account, the difference is 4 to 7 percent.
In 1960 about five percent of women and 16 percent of men completed a higher education; in 2023 it was about 64 percent of women and 45 percent of men.
In 2025, 32 percent of leaders were women, but only 19 percent of board members and 16 percent of chief executives.
The 2002 leave legislation has 52 weeks in total: four weeks before and 14 weeks after birth for the mother, two weeks for the father, and of the remaining 32 weeks each parent takes at least nine weeks.
Women take about 80 percent of the leave.
The Me Too movement spread in 2017, and broke through in Denmark in 2020 after Sofie Linde spoke.
Consent-based rape legislation came into force in 2021; consent can be expressed by words and by action.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which of the following subjects did the TV host Sofie Linde put focus on in a TV show in August 2020?
Option A: Terrorism.
Option B: Racism.
Option C: Sexism.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende emner satte tv-vært Sofie Linde fokus på i et tv-show i august 2020?  A: Terrorisme  |  B: Racisme  |  C: Sexisme
The answer is C: Sexism.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Sexisme
Question 2.
Are there more men or women who complete a higher education?
Option A: Men.
Option B: Women.
[DA] Er der flest mænd eller kvinder, der fuldfører en videregående uddannelse?  A: Mænd  |  B: Kvinder
The answer is B: Women.
It appeared in the June 2022 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Kvinder
Question 3.
Is there a rule in Danish law that an employer must give women and men equal pay for the same work?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er der i dansk lov en regel om, at en arbejdsgiver skal give kvinder og mænd lige løn for samme arbejde?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
That's the end of this part.
Well done.